okay gasps okay what's jumping back in
this and we are going to the end maybe I
don't know maybe I got lost the [ __ ]
woods I have to break this up into
another [ __ ] piece hopefully this is
the last episode okay okay let's just
see what's going on here
great I'm in a [ __ ] garage tired of
waking up in garage okay
okay okay okay
[ __ ] out of here yeah apparently over in
front of my [ __ ] eyes except oral
hadn't lived up those good fine
reputation he still hadn't found any of
the wealth contained in the mutts lands
[ __ ] I need to do is you know every time
we drive by the [ __ ] general store
it's something like blah blah blah Carl
hasn't found everything so that's why
he's like back well apparently that's a
[ __ ] clue that I haven't done
everything and that's why I should go
back
apparently the last person is actually
over there I checked it out that shit's
off the last [ __ ] ghosts or Ghoulies
the wall
and I should be able to go
hey it's funny because like this guy's
here just for like the one Hamilton
chemistry yeah since everyone's like
[ __ ] dad he's like squelching all the
[ __ ] like why does they need to find
like Lombards [ __ ] wealth even [ __ ]
alone I like [ __ ] freezing out here
alright let's say let's say
the branch
are we gonna have to load here am I
gonna place down but I know it probably
well
too bad
[Music]
should be a race yeah
let's just say that phrase okay guys can
every [ __ ] it turned off the car that
side that way
[ __ ] bear Stan Carl felt at the store
and its surrounding still held their
secrets and he didn't like to miss out
[ __ ] is that
they got
do they like turn into [ __ ] wolves or
something yeah that way
[ __ ] [ __ ] brushes everywhere
right
all right there with lots
I've heard of this place they [ __ ]
already [ __ ]
he's a [ __ ] waters any water around
here
am I in the right spot maybe I was
and feel like the right spot
over there
there's like not where I should be
[ __ ] be
look is this
today this is their own [ __ ] place
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] cold I said I really
like that they got the tree trying to
think because if they didn't climb a
tree trunk like the steps okay now it
stays that be [ __ ] lost I would be so
[ __ ] lost right now
okay maybe this is the wrong thing
there's a [ __ ] thing somewhere right
there
okay sort of like that way
that way
last night
all right something like it's over here
somewhere oh [ __ ]
two of them
like that chef
[ __ ] confused by what's out here
is that the story yes store holy [ __ ]
this [ __ ] wolves I love that [ __ ]
place
find out as it is talking phrasing
are all felt at the store and its
surroundings still held their secrets
and he didn't like to miss oh yeah Anna
there we go
a jibber read now coral spine as he
glanced over another body truck ah [ __ ]
airing out the scene was played out
Julie I can edit oh it's at sorry and
what one loves the was a hunting Lord
better yet a war diary
okay hello I'm a Sarah is that what
could be said great no holy [ __ ] that's
that one family suddenly appeared before
car that was the family's thing it was
like it's the numbers on a keychain
along with like the father in it I think
happy I say
ah
hey she is my lovely faded away like an
icicle melting in the palm of your hand
Carl back in the real world now you who
the ice bound man was oh [ __ ] it is
[ __ ] darkness towards manager himself
alright I gotta [ __ ] get in here cuz
it's [ __ ] hot I'm not caught oh yeah
forgot this dude's talking like that
yeah we got we got some heat and [ __ ] oh
my god I'm not gonna marry ya
let's see I think it's like all right
Sheila chances house is over there and
that's the one with the [ __ ] big like
family and [ __ ] money look at our
that you're not doing that [ __ ] here's
where all the fires are let's get that
[ __ ] out of here you got a wallet again
yeah
use it but silver balls
like an attic I guess
let's say that stretch
[Music]
a job
let me just take pill that drink
I can't guarantee Eastern
like barely
let's go let's go
yes
[Music]
what is up with this [ __ ] magic ice
thing
I guess I it's like that's the last
phantom lost in solitude up until now I
gotta join the others in the forests
darkness free at last to enjoy an
eternal well-deserved ro was only
beginning to understand the horror which
extract his village he understood that
the dead were piling up and that he
couldn't help them by himself the road
was clear for him he needed to push
further north and fast
let me make sure I got my it is
like on the right away okay [ __ ] dark
yeah yes straight against there go
around
[ __ ] it's snowy chuckles snowy out
here okay
like this
in some way or one sudden we are
together
not fire that [ __ ] up on assignment I
guess I run it I betcha take it stop
let's go yeah
another diary Karl felt like someone was
trying to communicate with them or was
it simply the result of happenstance
pieces that would in me blah blah
you better create a wall made of ice pop
it because I'm fast it's East the
Windigo
okay
this is what he was hunting
cheer up love that guy's got higher I
walk away walk back
the [ __ ] wind again Karl had found
what he was looking for he needed to get
back on the road
I have to get back on the road
not getting scary out here wait to get
back on the road
[ __ ] house and everything
scathed slides the door was unlocked his
aunt Carol felt kind of disappointed
that he wouldn't have to solve the
mystery of that padlock Carl reckoned
that the place was still inhabited less
than 24 hours ago said his detective
since tingled revealing to him or was it
the strong smell of wilderness in the
air this kind of most likely two men
these guys always expert yeah have to
find you
oh gee Pierre the poacher Blair was
definitely not the one who lived here
indeed Carl learned earlier that the man
had recently been shredded to death by
allegedly beasts
okay say Act two blankets
there were Douglas to seafood Averell
record
the jacket was still soaking wet the
poor man had surely unwillingly had a
taste of the market not too long ago
according to the pay stub that poor man
was Alexandra Blair and like that
okay
[ __ ] when they go up here
yeah
okay
it's cabin right
[ __ ] here's a [ __ ] glass it's better
anything else
that's dope
okay
I think we both know why there's a
handle for a flashlight so we can use
they got passed out
and
let me just make sure I'm going right
way yes
time or is it alkyl Oreo now Gloria okay
[ __ ] you up
okay this is the first one I just gone
straight [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay come on
oh yeah
well that's about now I'm not gonna ask
them any questions that I might the
other Bronx I know I wanna keep movin
[ __ ]
[ __ ] is this so cold already Carl did
not feel his toes anymore oh [ __ ] we're
going in there stick happen
right on till that point Karl had
believed that the object of this
crossbow hunting had dinner ravenous
wolf who was terrorizing the village but
as he noticed the height at which the
bolts had been fired he concluded that
the Beast had to have been as tall as a
man on his feet
seems like this place was long deserted
I gotta make wine here just one more
move for black to checkmate why
okay
please look at the map
just really to write
[ __ ] is that it's like a boat over there
other first
[ __ ]
Oh God [ __ ]
[ __ ] is that
okay
that makes it easy
I'm Zack
big
look like in there
is it
another [ __ ] well grant self-assertive
no objection
now like I laid out okay let's say okay
nothing the [ __ ] is that
I like my fire
I [ __ ] that up there is that the
[ __ ] one to go to more victims of
this ice plague Carl felt a chill down
his spine what if he was next my problem
[ __ ] Wendigo this is like a deer and
there's about are all felt the strong
pull the bug vision about me is that
that's the Windigo
it looked like a simple hunting accident
my god
there was Hamilton are all recognized
I made your hunting accident
that's what all that blood was okay I
get it
the doctor examined the young woman her
death couldn't be overturned she was
dead
it was not the type of body you buried
in a big ceremony in the village great
it has to be hidden no one would know
the best way to do that was to have a
simple-minded man buried the poor girl
Lamont mechanic the doctor denied the
unfair death of the young woman but
Hamilton had him in his room Hamilton
knew all of the poet's secrets and
wouldn't hesitate to reveal them I know
all about your crimes your little
communists you know mine what I sewed it
up there
Carll understood the ins and outs of the
affair a woman had been killed in an
unfair accident and a young warrior had
dammed himself to Avenger
here we go so when they go
but the one responsible had already been
killed and so the Beast would not quench
his thirst for vengeance reckless Carl
had full doubled from the beasts part at
least who was but a young tree man lost
without his penis out of hatred become
wendi-go obviously he
yeah that's
okay
I'm not better than everybody yes
now fastest gonna see this doesn't that
name are wolves in a minute pop I got
him
right in the freaking face
I don't I gotta go
now
I can count
face it the same as these bad
dad I got it hid ma'am
okay
[ __ ]
you see how where the [ __ ]
this man
and obvious that hey buddy
okay well it's gonna kick down
other when they go
caryl wonder how long he would have to
enjoy this skin stinging cold
a really good question I don't have the
answer to that question
[ __ ] [ __ ] civilization
okay
shoulda gonna picture the Medigap oh I
can't so get one
I got a picture that's one dick out
that's this up okay
sucks that suck okay I'm gonna [ __ ]
suppose Asian [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yourself
I got a blind pick Jotham
when you disappeared so did purity I
would defend purity against the winds
the tides against I second says could it
be that all this was but a story of
justice at vengeance yeah but no one's
gonna believe you say Paran I can get
paid
are these passionate feelings not
precisely the kind
feelings a good positive store
electrified people deep inside
no no no I'm gonna padded I'm taking pay
that I'll tap that I know that's a good
story
um I really like the atmosphere after
men it wasn't as free for a lit that it
be it should have been actually kinda
obvious to me that every time I went by
and I said there's more sacred so
should've thought that maybe there are
some more secrets
let's sit here um like the end and I was
all interesting nice to go through
around but yeah there's plenty and
plenty of goodies this one in Mason's
great narrow it is great there's almost
like Stanley parable phenomenal great
job everyone involved anyway thanks for
playing you'll see in the next one